when you put on the Super's you got so
I'm talking to you we're having a great
time right and suddenly I find the
reverse-flash I talk like this because
Marian is that right because you have to
if you listen to all those people to
play with the superheroes they all have
to talk like this which is cool on film
when you put it in real life they're
like what Gothel I'm gonna save it
you got a something about Hawthorne
prophet save Gotham I like can't even
can you speak up again know what that's
mean Tom Cavanaugh is loving his role on
the super hit series the flash and can't
wait for the Supergirl flash musical
crossover guys this is a very very big
deal
for all of us I don't know that any time
people have their favorite show they're
lining up sick okay now do it in song
and so what I like about our television
show is we've been unafraid to push the
boundaries our pedigree is such that if
anyone was going to do a musical I think
I'm famous had something to go we're
worth buying and your watch is like oh
my god he sold it I'm so sold it goes
over what's been called under self and
what feels like Gilmore Girls and Will
and Grace returning to the small screen
with Tom be open to reprising his role
on it I should be patient
what I'm fine with the four years that
we had it was a for us personally a real
a real treasure we perceive some
gratitude for having Oliver do that
musical well there you go
there's a nice nervous there you go